[Music]
in Ko new not shut out Shh submitted by
Carlos with the eyes
woo sexy eyes are death eyes you know
your crazy ass
Oh a controversial knockout creates
chaos after kickboxing spectators into
the back with TAC one of the fighters
saw this [ __ ] I don't know what it is I
saw the title in it no one was something
bad happened in the ring I don't want to
root for you but just watch the video we
have a video - I showed me the Libya who
like to videos right back to back it
edited yo 28 seconds long ok
I don't know not want to ever get kicked
by I do not know what I did and it's not
a girl a jacking off to a monkey Dean
Edell feelin baby farting has a video so
this is a kickboxing championship held
and Paris it's called glory 42 this is a
welterweight class an difference between
her root Gregorian and Myrtle groom
hearts
that's some crazy ass names yeah so
Gregorian is Armenian fighting out of
Belgium and Grune heart is Dutch
fighting us no no no no that's a
different kind with the little babies
fruit heart or Gregorian and it was crew
heart who won round one according to all
sides
oh yeah
watch what happens after though I
believe it was a need right there
now Gregoria Sturgis monfriez death no
you gotta keep fighting
we came over the other day was that
gregorian schemer was it fan because
Gloria's team I believe yeah so the rep
didn't call a time out or anything
no because it's still legal in the game
because he didn't take the me so it
seems like what happened was when you
got hit him in the head with me it was
so like Bridal just brain because he
just drops his hand he turned around and
that's when that dude went around his
phone no this is just like the [ __ ]
uh what's it called the Mayweather thing
you know with eight with a touch gloves
Eagles class and just knocks him but
basically what happened was like he
head-butted Mayweather and this was like
his last biggest fight and what happened
with that is that after you head-butted
him he apologized he gave him a hug and
then he didn't keep his gloves oh so he
hugged them and they made one just knock
him out what yeah those that I hope you
gentlemen I can't remember that yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy it was like lying
sucker punch yeah I mean I can at the
end of the day yeah in terms of like
fighting boxing rules it's legal fight
was on
when fights on you keep the gloves up so
people are like yeah it was legal but in
terms of sportsmanship know if he came
to apologize yeah could be apologizing
in the middle of the fight it could be
head-butted him it was a dirty move and
then you know he was like he gave him a
hug and the Wrightwood he hugged he
believed his head like this he knocks
him out ah that's absurdity
sportsmanship wise terrible is it okay
within the rules yes because white will
still on shoulda kept this gloves up I
mean that one was clearly the fight was
still on I don't know why he turned
around and started walking back to his
corner being like his brain got rattled
oh it seemed like there's no reason just
no and I couldn't find reports on who
jumped in it they're just saying that
spectators don't do it looked like his
team is saying that they had matching
shirts and everything yeah I thought it
was so dope though because like David
was saying I think in the kickboxing
rules he [ __ ] up you started walking
away but I think in terms of like the
code of man and like the code of honor I
think that was turned
yeah his back was turned and so usually
we'll fight someone when they turn their
back on you and then his boys were like
man [ __ ] that male came in and when you
watch him jump that dude you can tell
all those trainers also for that black
dude was actually scared like you was
like you look like [ __ ] I'm getting
[ __ ] up right now
I've never fought so I don't know like
in terms of adrenaline or I've never
fought in like a ring like that like a
controlled setting
so I don't know it's like in the midst
of it all what's going on to do now it's
really going on so like if they were to
turn around like for me at least again
from various guys when a very ignorant
point of view um like would it would I
feel like oh [ __ ] he's turning around to
set something up because in my head the
fights still going on even if it turns
around and I'm like cool like you're
always looking for an advantage point
that's a possibility yeah you really
don't know what they're doing like
there's true we've seen people where
like someone like they kick them in the
nuts and the person that did the kinking
knows he [ __ ] up on accident so he
didn't reach out with my bad I didn't
need to do that and then there's times
where guys like they just kick but
they're still in the zone and when they
kick them in the nuts that guy is going
like this and he not doesn't know that
he kicked them in a nuts
he's oh cool he's hurt because you have
your predator like mindset ah yeah
and so what this seemed like it could be
like oh cool he's hurt imma go and
finish the job without thinking wait is
he okay yeah so that's that for me right
now I'm kind of like I don't know I
don't know if I feel any sort of like
anger towards any party because I'm like
you are in a fight and you're at the
peak of your aggression and you're in
the zone and because the difference
between this fight and the mayweather
fight was but God came up any hug him
you know so he knew that he hugged them
and he wanted to touch gloves in game on
but it was hug pow pow you know this
one's more like it was in the midst of
fighting he like what the [ __ ] I had his
hands job and he was walking back to his
corner like a zombie that's what was
like man I was a clear sucker punch
but also the ref was saying yo you the
fight still going yeah the ref was
telling him come on you know yeah yeah
the announcers are saying like always
I forgot the same but she just loves up
yeah keep your gloves up like women yeah
so here is crude heart and Gregorian I
just love his trainers like his boys
okay one more time this boys has jumped
in immediately like that's it that's the
team that you want here we go yeah I
like bad and [ __ ] you didn't give a [ __ ]
green heart and for Gregorian it was
are who won round one according to round
three
yeah that's clearly he's walking to the
corner
Garth dropping everything look at that
boom drop he chases after him yes time
he clearly knows that nah dude
that's the weird thing though for some
reason when I look at this I just see as
a fighter though his guard was down and
the fight was still on so if he's
supposed to dis be like you know that
was in the second round right yeah you
know the rest the rest man I mean do you
think that he might have suffered a
concussion at that moment his icing look
glazed or anything else he just looked
like you probably misheard something so
in kickboxing you can't knee in the head
different Federation has different rules
because it seems like maybe that wasn't
a legal move nobody would look at the
rest it's being reported like it was
perfectly legal move oh then I dunno the
heart is hard to keep that's his fault
dude it really is his fault that's his
fault right oh oh yeah like a sucker
punch because of the did you mention
earlier like the sportsmanship about it
yeah but at the same time it's like it's
almost like so stupid you know I mean
you would never think that that happened
yeah kind of like I guess like what you
were saying it's like what the [ __ ] you
know the fight was still laughing ah
yeah yeah and the other guys literally
arms distance away so it was like you
threw the knee
you threw the knee and then you went a
full and when he turns around just even
threw another tiny wood you don't have
to take one step I think he's got it I
think from the person that punched point
of view he really doesn't really know
what's going on all the way at the other
side of the ring and he sees them turn
around he's running a front I think
that's different but when you're in like
when you just traded blows right and it
just [ __ ] wailing when you get out of
that trade you're still wanting to trade
oh yeah you don't know what's going on
really yeah so he just got in like the
trade and it came out oh [ __ ] okay boom
that's true we're looking at the
perspective on Grigorian square we
should look at it on the other side and
see what it looks like not even her
glory ins but we're looking at it from a
perspective of people that are in a very
calm state of mind
and we're sitting down and we get to
take in the whole situation I just don't
understand why the [ __ ] he stopped being
turned around I don't get it what was
going on in his head I don't know hey
maybe you might have gotten a concussion
yeah it didn't happen well not a
concussion but there's something
obviously like he heard something Robbie
I got you got a acid I hear interview
from that dude like what the [ __ ] were
you thinking dude yeah so Grune heart is
saying that he just needs a [ __ ] ton of
backlash obviously from this thing which
kind of sucks good yeah I think you
should though he didn't even do anything
wrong really
he's even received a death threat people
are pissed but then he said I was too
long yeah he's saying that afterwards he
did speak with Krekorian and that
Grigorian said that he would have done
yeah yeah I was like oh so much you're
trading blows he goes boom of course
you're gonna get hit you know what I
mean
how that his fault you're still within
the match there wasn't any rep
interference he wasn't telling people to
break it up there wasn't a mutual thing
where they were playing gaps for an
apology
he just stopped yeah if you stopped her
in a match gonna get your ass [ __ ]
knocked out that's a little different
dude this one's kind of like a yeah the
green heart is just saying standing
right like I don't regret anything like
it was perfectly legal and even he said
he would do it yeah let it go how many
fights has grown hot half also if he's
not known to be a dirty fighter like you
happens but if he's like one of those
guys that's always doing something
slightly shady always kicking in the
nuts you're in there you know that I
think it's different is one of those
[ __ ]
he's I've been in total of 91 fight damn
you know see five wins 37 by knockout
twenty-eight three losses two by
knockout and it's really good yeah so
like I mean people could pie look at his
track record and see if he's a dirty
fighter or a clean fighter it's not like
he's Michael Bisping misshapen
yeah his aka is the predator so he's on
the hunt that's not how he fights that
is what it is though his corner get in
trouble for jumping on something I'm
pretty sure they did I think it's a sin
to - yes and I'm
that's just dope though I love that when
I thought I don't like [ __ ] yeah that's
a good team three fat Armenians and
they're like hey javi and I don't know I
wouldn't know what what's going on I
would have just been like why did you
turn like I would be so stuck on my
corner just being like why'd you [ __ ]
turn what the [ __ ] what what if I would
be registering it but they were just you
sucker-punch my homie yeah what was the
reason do you know you don't god I gotta
look that [ __ ] up but that's what's
killing me I think that's how you put it
hands down
that's the first thing that'll come into
my mind and we just I can't even focus
that I just really you why she turned
why'd you turn she turned around I just
a bell went off like evening Dew yeah
yeah it look like maybe that's what he
heard in his head
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only if
it's positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby